inde smash-hit stardew valley has sold  over 400,000 copies that's not bad for a  game developed entirely by one guy but  in an interview with PC gamer creator  eric barone confirmed that there are  still some secrets no one has discovered  considering the amount of people playing  the game that's pretty impressive but  that's not all the developer teased  barone says he wants to expand every  single area of the game with a big free  update fans have made plenty of requests  and he's open to answering them  these include more marriage candidates  and a cooperative mode Barone doesn't  have an estimate on when this content  will release as he doesn't want to make  any promises he can't keep  stardew valley released on february 26th  and it's been quite successful ever  since if you want to see more of the  game in action we've got a hefty 40  minutes of gameplay up on GameSpot and  for all the stardew valley updates  you're already in the right place